fährt er märz sie haben sich mit dem
text den sie sich vorbereitet haben wir
ein manuskript ja sehr viel mühe gegeben
allerdings muss man ausdrücklich sagen
das was sie hier vorgetragen hat sind
lauter fragen sie sind hier durch die
sache durch die tänze und haben nichts
konkretes gesagt moore bieten wäre
wirklich sehr vernünftig gewesen
wenn sie nicht mit durchkommen immer nur
fragen zu stellen und sich niemals in
irgendeiner frage sinnvoll zu
positionieren und wenn sie es dann
machen dann wird's peinlich also 7
sie kritisieren her dass ich mit dem
russischen präsidenten telefoniert
und sie kritisieren hier das sich mit
dem russischen präsidenten die tiere von
mehreren tieren das dann sagen sie ich
soll was gemeinsames mit dem
französischen präsident machen und
während sie in ihrer rede dass in
simuliert haben haben sie völlig
übersehen das letzte telefongespräche
waren gemeinsam mit dem französischen
präsidenten übrigens eine europäische
aktion dieser beiden länder die eine
wichtige rolle für die zukunft europas
spielen
und ganz anders als sie das hier
herstellen sind die anderen länder
europas überwiegend sehr sehr froh
darüber dass wir genau das machen und
freuen sich darüber dass wir mit ihnen
unsere erkenntnisse austauschen dass wir
darüber reden was gemeinsam vorzutragen
ist und was wir tun wollen naja dann
hatten sie ja noch einen konkreten
vorschlag den muss man sich ja doch noch
mal auf der zunge zergehen lassen ihr
vorschlag den sie heute hier im
deutschen bundestag gemacht haben ist
dass wir die steuern für fast alle
bürgerinnen bürger über ein soli erhöhen
sollen um die bessere ausrüstung der
bundeswehr zu bezahlen was für ein
merkwürdiger einfach
einen ganzen bundestagswahlkampf haben
sie damit geführt zu sagen dass der soli
auch für die leute die 200 300 und 400
tausend euro im jahr verdienen weg muss
um dann jetzt vorzuschlagen dass leute
die 70.000 60.000 euro verdient den soli
jetzt aber zahlen sollen damit das jetzt
hier gemacht werden können das ist keine
gute idee
und ich werde ihre fragen beantworten
oder sie sind alle längst beantwortet
bei den gelegenheiten dazu da waren aber
ich will ausdrücklich dazu sagen eins
ist schon ganz ganz zentral wenn man
über das redet was wir reden auch wenn
es um die verbesserung unserer
verteidigungsanstrengungen geht dann
muss man als oppositionsführer der von
der cdu csu kommt schon sagen die
verteidigungsministerin und minister der
letzten jahre waren in der cdu und der
csu die kanzlerin weil der cdu und
darüber hätten sie auch noch nix ein
wort verlieren
die schlechte zeit für die bundeswehr
hat begonnen als ein presse china viel
kommunizieren da selten sich in seinem
amt aufhalten
bundesverteidigungsminister guttenberg
entschieden hat alles mögliche anders zu
machen ordentlich einzusparen die
wehrpflicht abzuschaffen und darunter
leiden wir noch heute dass all das geld
damals diesen gesprächen brauchen
manchmal ist sacharbeit wirklich eine
nützliche sache ernst
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
die preise für benzin und diesel für
lebensmittel und fürs heizen steigen
rasant und millionen bürgerinnen und
bürger fragen sich jeden tag komme ich
ihn mit meinem geld reicht es noch am
monatsende
das sind sehr sehr sehr gravierende
fragen fragen auf die es in der tat eine
klare antwort braucht die
bundesregierung hat umfangreiche
entlastung für bürgerinnen und bürger
und unternehmen auf den weg gebracht in
der summe reden wir über mehr als 30
milliarden euro
und diese entlastungen kommen jetzt an
in den nächsten tagen und wochen
rückwirkend ab januar wird die
pendlerpauschale erhöht um die hohen
spritpreise etwas auszugleichen ab
ersten juli werden die stromrechnung
günstiger weil wir die eeg-umlage
streichen eine vierköpfige familie spart
zu mehrere hundert euro im jahr und ab
juli bekommen bürgerinnen bürger mit
kleinen einkommen wohngeldempfänger
rinnen und studierende mit bafög einen
zuschuss zu den heizkosten
familien werden gezielt entlastet durch
den kinderbonus von armut betroffene
kinder und jugendliche erhalten einen
sofort zuschlag und zwar monatlich jeder
beschäftigte erhält ab september zum
ausgleich für die gestiegenen
energiekosten einmalig 300 euro
ausgezahlt und schon heute treten zwei
maßnahmen kraft über die wohl am meisten
geredet worden es in deutschland in den
vergangenen wochen die steuersenkung auf
benzin und diesel und das neun euro
ticket im öpnv
dass damit die liebe die nicht aufs auto
verzichten können und all diejenigen die
täglich bus und bahn nutzen und
vielleicht gewinnen wir auch die eine
oder andere in den anderen dafür künftig
etwas häufiger die öffentlichen
verkehrsmittel zu nutzen jedenfalls ist
der ansturm auf das neue euro ticket
ganz massiv und es zeigt die maßnahmen
wirken sie kommen direkt bei den
bürgerinnen und bürgern an und das hat
diese bundesregierung und die
regierungsmehrheit im bundestag auf den
dicht gepackt
weil die öffentlichkeit
ja ihre eigenen themen hat die
diskutieren die scheiben der
öffentlichkeit ist es so dass das
vielleicht noch nicht so präsent
geworden es immer wenn das geld denn
jetzt gezahlt wird dann hoffe ich wird
den bürgern und bürgern die diese hilfe
wirklich dringend brauchen auch sichtbar
es kommt und das haben wir gemacht
übrigens profitieren auch die renten und
rentner von den entlastungs paketen bei
der stromrechnung zum tank rabatt und
dem neuen euro ticket und zum ersten
juli steigen die renten so stark wie
seit jahrzehnten nicht um 6,1 prozent 12
prozent im osten und über 5,35 im westen
für drei millionen rentnern rentner
haben wir höhere erwerbsminderungsrenten
auf den weg gebracht und wir werden das
rentenniveau bei 48 prozent
stabilisieren damit es nicht nach 2025
unterschritten wird das ist eine
wichtige leistung dieser region
wer sein leben lang gearbeitet und
beiträge gezahlt hat der muss sich auf
seine oder ihre rente verlassen können
das ist ein kernversprechen des
sozialstaates und wir werden das
erneuern
und in diesen zeiten wo große
veränderungen stattfinden da ist es umso
wichtiger dass sich alle verlassen
können auf sicherheit und zusammenhalt
wir entlasten übrigens auch die
unternehmen vor allem diejenigen die
jetzt mit dem krieg und den hohen
energiekosten zu kämpfen haben und haben
ein schutzschild errichtet und betreibt
das betrieben bei bedarf mit zuschüssen
wirtschaft nur der günstigen krediten
unter die arme zu greifen
mit dem ähnlichen instrumenten haben wir
es geschafft durch die korona pandemie
zu kommen und es ist gelungen
arbeitsplätze zu erhalten das ist eine
gute botschaft vor allem wenn wir jetzt
sagen können die beschäftigung ist
gegenwärtig höher als vor der pandemie
es zeigt wenn ein land zusammenhält dann
kann man auch durch schwere krisen
kommen und diesen weg werden wir weiter
verfolgen
aber ich sage ganz offen
natürlich ist damit das problem
steigender preise noch nicht gelöst
denn der preisanstieg hat eine ganze
reihe von ursachen
ganz vorn der von russland angezettelten
krieg
was machen sie der von russland
angezettelten krieg
er heizt die energie und rohstoffpreise
an die internationalen lieferketten sind
oft noch die pandemie gestört
insbesondere in asien man sollte sich
nur einmal die vorstellung
vergegenwärtigen von den vielen schiffen
in den container hilfen chinas
insbesondere in shanghai und natürlich
haben die milliardenschweren
konjunkturpakete die viele länder nicht
nur wir aufgelegt haben dazu geführt
dass es eine höhere nachfrage gibt zum
beispiel nach rohstoffen
noch sind also diese preissteigerung
wahrscheinlich auf solche einmaligen
shops zurückzuführen aber wir müssen
aufpassen
aber wir müssen aufpassen dass daraus
keine dauerhafte entwicklung mit zu
hohen inflationsrate bei allem was wir
heute und auch künftig tun ist eins klar
kreditfinanzierte
dauersubventionen sind keine lösung
zumal wir nächstes jahr die
verfassungsmäßig vorgeschriebenen
schuldenbremse wieder beachtet werden
ziel muss also sein den inflationsdruck
nachhaltig zu mildern und zugleich
behalten wir weiterhin die finanzielle
lage von rentnern rentnern von
grundsicherungsempfänger von
studentinnen und studenten und familien
genau im blick auch die arbeitnehmern
und arbeitnehmer fragen sich was sie
sich noch werden leisten können
die tarifpartner in der chemieindustrie
haben kürzlich einen sehr interessanten
weg gewählt
beschlossen wurden gestiegene preise
schnell und substanziell auszugleichen
über eine einmalige sonderzahlung auch
in der stahlindustrie wird darüber
gerade diskutiert auch in anderen
tarifen zum beispiel passieren haben
einmalige zahlung haben zahlung eine
rolle gespielt
die gute idee dahinter ist den
arbeitnehmern und arbeitnehmern
finanziell luft zu verschaffen ohne die
arbeitgeber zu überfordern und
inflationsrisiken anzuheizen
ich habe mich deshalb zusammen mit allen
verantwortlichen der regierung zu einem
ungewöhnlichen schritt entschlossen ich
möchte die arbeitnehmerin arbeitnehmer
ihre gewerkschaften und die arbeitgeber
zu einer konzertierten aktion
zusammenrufen
das hat schon einmal geholfen dass wir
zusammen gestanden haben gewerkschaften
arbeitgeber staat auch viele andere die
verantwortung in diesem land haben um
mit einer schwierigen herausforderung
umzugehen und ich finde es ist richtig
wenn instrumente der zusammenarbeit und
des zusammenhalts von unternehmen von
beschäftigten von gewerkschaften
unternehmerverbänden von start von
kommunen von allen institutionen schon
einmal in schwierigen lagen geholfen
haben zu sagen hier muss erneut
zusammengestanden werden und
herausgefunden werden wie wollen wir mit
dieser preisentwicklung umgehen ich bin
dazu bereit dass wir uns so
zusammentreffen
natürlich wird das keine aktivität sein
wo wir uns treffen und mal reden da wird
ganz konkret gesprochen und ich will
auch sagen alle werden etwas beitragen
müssen die sozialpartner die arbeitgeber
selbstverständlich denn sie haben eine
große verantwortung dafür dass die
finanzkraft ihrer beschäftigten groß
genug ist aber auch wir als gemeinschaft
und der staat und deshalb ist es eben
umso wichtiger dass wir das miteinander
machen wir brauchen eine gezielte
krankheit kraftanstrengung in einer ganz
außergewöhnlichen situation und wir sind
dazu bereit wir wollen eine konzertierte
aktion gegen den preisdruck
das ist natürlich keine lohn
verhandlungsrunde das machen die
tarifpartner aber es geht darum das
miteinander zu besprechen und ich weiß
aus den gesprächen mit den
verantwortlichen im gewerkschaften und
arbeitgeberverbänden und
unternehmensverbänden dass sie das sehr
begrüßen wenn wir genau das jetzt machen
die korona pandemie hat uns gezeigt wie
wichtig gesellschaftlicher zusammenhalt
ist ich wünsche mir dass wir das
bewahren die aktuelle infektions lage
verschafft uns zeit zum handeln wir
nutzen sie intensiv um uns und unser
gesundheitssystem gut auf herbst und
winter vorzubereiten und sie stellen
unser gesundheitssystem so auf dass es
zukunftssicher ist dazu gehört die
gesetzliche krankenversicherung
verlässlich zu finanzieren
darauf können sich die patienten und
patienten aber auch die beschäftigten im
gesundheitswesen verlassen die in den
vergangenen zweieinhalb jahren so
unglaublich viel geleistet haben für
unser land und wir werden sie nicht
vergessen und sie weiter unterstützen
weil der zusammenhalt so wichtig ist
werden auch sozialreform weiter eine
rolle spielen es ist nicht so dass das
alles jetzt verschwindet hinter dem
krieg herr merz sondern es bleibt gerade
in dieser situation ganz ganz wichtig
dass wir etwas für den zusammenhalt tun
und deshalb werden wir die reformen
weiter voran bringen die wir uns als
regierung vorgenommen haben das
bürgergeld mit dem wir auf beratung
unterstützung setzen statt auf unnötige
bürokratie und und komplizierte
antragsverfahren und die
kindergrundsicherung die
unübersichtliche vielzahl
unterschiedlicher familienleistung
zusammenführen und verbessern soll alles
beides wird weiter vorangebracht
kinder und jugendliche die in armut
aufwachsen darf es an einem so reichen
land wie deutschland nicht geben das ist
ein grundsatz der für diese regierung
unabdingbare täter
und selbstverständlich gehört dazu auch
dass wir jetzt
voran bringen was wir uns letztes jahr
vorgenommen haben
nämlich dass diejenigen die am wenigsten
verdienen einen besseren lohn bekommen
der mindestlohn wird ab oktober auf 12
euro unter stunde steigen es war ein
langer kampf jetzt wird das realität das
versprechen ist umgesetzt
wir wissen alle dass zwölf euro in der
stunde keine großen sprünge erlauben
aber es ist eine erleichterung für viele
die sehr sehr wenig geld haben gerade
wenn jetzt die preise steigen und es
macht einen unterschied für sechs
millionen bürgern und bürger was für
eine aussage über unser land und was
hier verdient wird aber wie dringlich
ist diese reform gut dass jetzt kommt
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen faire
löhne sind das eine aber viele
bürgerinnen und bürger stellen sich
grundsätzlichere fragen wie sicher ist
der arbeitsplatz wenn energie teurer
wird und lieferketten unsicherer wie
geht es weiter mit dem industrieland
deutschland
ich kann das gut verstehen und wir
wissen alle dass wir vor einer zweiten
industriellen revolution stehen nur ein
beispiel um in zukunft mit sauberen
strom betrieben zu werden braucht ein
chemie standort ludwigshafen mit basf in
etwa die strommenge von acht bis neun
windparks auf see
das klingt viel und das ist es auch
die gute nachricht ist schon vor den
kriegsbeginn in der ukraine hatte die
bundesregierung einen zukunftsplan um
das industrieland deutschland bis 2045
co2 neutral zu machen und dieser plan
gilt heute immer noch mehr als vorher
zwei dinge sind dafür entscheidend
erstens versorgungssicherheit energie
muss immer verfügbar sein 24 stunden am
tag 365 tage im jahr
die bundesregierung hat zuletzt
erhebliche fortschritte durchgesetzt um
unabhängig von russischen gast zu werden
schwimmende flüssiggasterminals werden
kurzfristig bereit stehen mit einem
eigenen gesetz beschleunigen wir den
ausbau so dass in wenigen monaten und
nicht den jahren und jahrzehnten die
nötige infrastruktur errichtet wird
erschließen neue bezugsquellen
erst vorige woche habe ich dazu
gespräche in afrika geführt wir reden
auch mit norwegen mit kanada den usa und
katar
und terminals und leistung sondern
künftig auch für wasserstoff genutzt
werden denn darin liegt die zukunft
zweitens der ausbau der erneuerbaren
energien wird massiv beschleunigt
das oster paket ist bereits
verabschiedet zwei weitere pakete folgen
im sommer und erz und wir wollen die
dauer der verwaltungsverfahren
mindestens halbieren und das
was will ich an dieser stelle auch sehr
klar sagen
wir werden uns nicht den schneid
abkaufen lassen meine damen und herren
nicht von den lobbyisten nicht von den
bedenkenträgern und auch nicht von den
verteidigern des status quo denn wenn
wir erst einmal anfangen dinge auf die
zeitschiene zu schieben dann werden wir
niemals rechtzeitig fertig werden es ist
zu lang wir haben die zeit dafür nicht
mehr dieses jahr ist das jahr der
entscheidung und entscheidung werden
gekocht
mit meinen kolleginnen und kollegen und
aus den niederlanden dänemark belgien
und dem kommissionspräsidenten von
allein haben wir kürzlich die weichen
gestellt um aus nordseewind so etwas zu
machen wäre ein riesiges windenergie
kraftwerk das gleiche wollen wir für die
ostsee erreichen und die kommission hat
auch ihren beitrag geleistet mit dem
paket repower you das dazu beitragen
soll dass viele dinge schneller gehen
und in vielen fragen die jetzt von
einigen im vordergrund diskutiert werden
ist ja eine sache dabei ganz zu trauen
es sollen noch mal neue möglichkeiten
der beschleunigung beinhalten damit
verfahren einfacher werden und wird die
dinge besser voranbringen können auch
darüber haben wir bei der sondertagung
des europäischen rates gesprochen und es
bleibt ein ziel für ganz europa was für
uns unmittelbar geld wir wollen energie
unabhängigkeit erreichen so schnell wie
möglich das wissen wir ist diesen tagen
ganz ganz dringend angesichts des
russischen angriff
und wir wollen vollständige co2
neutralität bis 2045 erreichen das ist
machbar beides gehört zusammen es
schließt einander nicht aus und wir
werden beides erreichen
natürlich gehört dazu dass wir auch
jetzt die grundlagen dafür legen all das
voranzubringen was für unser land
wichtig ist bei forschung und innovation
bei digitalisierung wo wir mehr tempo
brauchen bei der aus und weiterbildung
und deshalb schaffen wir ein
qualifizierungs geld deshalb wollen wir
neue aufstiegsmöglichkeiten schaffen und
chancengerechtigkeit ist mein
startchance programm wir bauen die
ganztagsbetreuung an schulen aus den
grundschulen die bafög-reform läuft und
wir wollen uns für eine
ausbildungsgarantie einsetzen damit
jugendlichen einen berufseinstieg nicht
verwehrt bleibt alles gastes investition
denn wir brauchen die diese
investitionen in unsere zukunft wir
brauchen die besten der finderin die
weltbesten ingenieure gut ausgebildete
facharbeiterinnen und facharbeiter
ich habe eingangs über die erwartungen
der bürger haben bürger gesprochen wäre
fragen und sorgen die wir in den
mittelpunkt unserer politik stellen und
die aktuell größte sorge ist ganz
unbedingt der furchtbaren krieg den
russland gegen die ukraine begonnen hat
uns alle schmerzen die schmerz die opfer
dieses verbrecherischen krieges der ja
nun schon fast 100 tage wird mit jedem
tag steigen die opferzahlen
mit jedem tag werden mehr städte und
orte in trümmerwüste verwandelt
angesichts der russischen bomben und
artillerie und deshalb ist so wichtig
dass wir uns über das einig sind was wir
erreichen und putin darf und wird diesen
krieg nicht gewinnen
und es gibt jetzt eine situation in der
immer wieder darüber diskutiert wird was
die kriegsziele sind unsere unser ziel
ist dass putin nicht gewinnt unser ziel
ist dass die ukraine sich verteidigen
kann und damit erfolgreich aber ich will
ausdrücklich sagen ich will ausdrücklich
sagen es ist überheblich und es ist
unangemessen und es ist völlig fehl am
platze wenn hier zu lange darüber
diskutiert wird was die ukraine
richtigerweise zu entscheiden hat ich
sage es mit dem amerikanischen
präsidenten über die ukraine entscheiden
die ukraine ukraine und niemand sonst
eher herz
man muss fielen genau zuhören was sie da
machen und dann höre ich viel was mir
nicht gefällt ich höre auf hier aus
anderen den andern ländern lasse
diskutiert wird das will ich
ausdrücklich sagen da gibt es den einen
oder anderen der vielleicht auch denkt
so könnte das doch gelingen dann ist die
sache endlich vorbei aber das kann nicht
sein wir werden die ukraine ukraine so
lange unterstützen wie das erforderlich
es mit allen möglichkeiten die wir auf
den weg gebracht haben
zudem darf seine ziele nicht erreichen
er darf nicht mit seinem konzept
durchkommen mit einem brutalen
militärischen einsatz ein land zu
erobern oder teile davon das ist im
tourismus und den werden wir in europa
nicht akzeptieren
gestern trafen unsere tiefgreifende sagt
sie es sind übrigens die
weitreichendsten sanktionen die jemals
gegen ein so großes land weltweit
verhängt worden sind es sind sehr
wirksame sanktionen auch das muss dazu
gesagt werden und sitzt interaktionen
mit dem putin niemals gerechnet hat weil
es sanktionen sind die
ausgeschlossenheit entstanden sind und
gerade dadurch ihre wirksamkeit
entfalten diese geschlossenheit müssen
wir bewahren
und deshalb ist es gut dass
sich der europäische rat erst nach dem
15 paketen die vorher beschlossen waren
auf 1 6 verständigt hat mit vielen
weiteren sehr detaillierten sanktionen
an dem wir lange gearbeitet haben und
auch mit einem ölembargo das dazugehört
ich bin froh dass diese entscheidung
jetzt getroffen worden ist
und steigen zum herbst aus der import
russischer kohle aus und für uns in
deutschland gilt trotz der ausnahme für
die pipeline anrainer wir werden
unverändert daran arbeiten bis zum
jahresende auch aus dem import von ole
book von öl auszusteigen das bleibt
unverändert unser ziel
außerdem unterstützen wir die ukraine
finanziell mit sehr sehr viel mittel
gerade erst haben wir eine milliarde
zugesagt im rahmen der g7 eine direkte
zahlung aus deutschland die dazu
beitragen soll dass die ukraine dieser
situation hätte erwerben kann der sie
der gefahr herr werden kann der sie
ausgesetzt ist und
neben der wirtschaftlichen und
finanziellen unterstützung
wie können wir auch waffen
eines will ich klarstellen
deutschland muss sich da nicht
verstecken
wir liefern kontinuierlich von beginn
des krieges an
und unmittelbar nach kriegsbeginn haben
wir diese entscheidung getroffen und mit
einer langjährigen preis staatspraxis in
deutschland gebrochen das war eine
richtige entscheidung aber es war eine
mutige neue entscheidung dieser
regierung meine dann
und weil sie ja nur fragen durch die
landschaft getänzelt sind herr merz noch
mal der hinweis
es ist eine regierung die von der cdu
geführt worden ist die diese stadt ist
die letzten jahre hatte ich will das
nicht kritisieren aber so zu tun als sei
das nicht irgendein ganz besonders
weitreichender schritt gewesen worden
dass wir das jetzt gemacht haben das ist
nicht in ordnung und auch nicht
vernünftig
zeitenwende das ist der furchtbare
imperialistische angriff russlands auf
sein nachbarland das unschuldig
überfallen worden ist dass wir darauf
reagieren
das sind weitreichende maßnahmen und zu
diesen weitreichenden maßnahmen zählte
schon als allererstes dass wir diese
staatspraxis verändert haben ich
verstehe nicht wie dann immer wieder von
ihm vorgetragen würde es sei nichts
verliert sie allein das ist eine massive
ende und der politik in deutschland
wenige tage nach kriegsausbruch haben
wir flugabwehrraketen und
panzerabwehrwaffen geliefert also genau
das was zu dem zeitpunkt am dringendsten
nötig war dazu kommen bislang mehr als
15 millionen schuss munition
hunderttausend handgranaten über 5000
panzer abwärme ihn umfangreiches
sprengmaterial
maschinengewehre dutzende lastwagen
ladungen mit sonstigen relevanten gütern
zb zur drohen hat mehr für mobilität
kommunikation und zur verpflegung ist
versorgung verwundeter
gemeinsam mit dänemark haben wir der
ukraine auf ihren wunsch hin 54
modernisierte gepanzerte
truppentransporter geliefert über einen
ersten ringtausch mit unseren
tschechischen freunden bekommt die
ukraine vertrautes gerät so britischer
bauart zunächst 20 kampfpanzer t 72 wir
sorgen für ersatz für tschechien weitere
gespräche laufen
erst gestern habe ich mit dem
griechischen ministerpräsidenten
mitsotakis verabredet dass griechenland
schützenpanzer aus ehemaligen informer
beständen liefern wird und wird dafür
die griechischen bestände mit deutschen
schützenpanzern auffüllen und auch das
sollte nicht
vergessen und beiseite getan werden
zu unserer unterstützung gehört auch
dass die bundeswehr ist 168 besonders
schwer verwundete ukrainische soldaten
ausgeflogen und hier in deutschland
behandelt hat
wir helfen als ein umfangreicher weise
und das könnte auch zur kenntnis
genommen werden und nicht durch fragen
und frage gestellt werden die einfach
mit fakten nichts zu tun haben das ist
ja nur eine flucht aus der tatsache dass
die realität mit dem was sie hier in sie
ihren nicht übereinstimmt dass sie
fragen stellen um nicht zugeben zu
müssen dass die frage beantworten wäre
und zwar sehr gut
aber es geht weiter
in der letzten woche hat die ukraine den
vertrag mit der rüstungsindustrie über
die gebhard flaig panzer unterzeichnet
die rund dreiwöchige schulung läuft
dieser tage an und
das will ich ausdrücklich sagen die
wurden von der ukraine gewünscht ich
habe in den talkshows dieser republik
gehört das gesagt wurde die wollen das
gar nicht hier im bundestag haben das
auch welche erzählt ganz naseweis haben
sie berichtete wie sie eben über
terminvereinbarung ehrlicherweise dass
barney und zu keinem zeitpunkt richtig
dass es eine hochwirksame eine hoch
schwere waffe um diesen komischen
begriff zu benutzen und sie wird
eingesetzt werden in der ukraine
der ein oder andere könnte ja mal seine
ganzen äußerung die da in der hitze des
gefechts in diesem fall so gesagt hat
noch einmal überprüfen da ist ganz schön
viel was einfach mit der wirklichkeit
nichts zu tun hat dabei und es kommt
diese waffe mit einer erstausstattung
von 59.000 schuss munition und das
reicht für 1200 bekämpfung vorgänger da
habe ich ja auch fehler welche gehört
und gelesen die gesagt haben dass seine
artillerie wache mit der man nicht zum
beispiel flugzeuge bekämpft oder drogen
die reinen bedrohen sondern das sei
etwas das einfach darin zu nutzen würde
in die gegend zu schießen und
anderswohin das ist nicht richtig
gewesen und trotzdem durften hier leute
überall in deutschland diesen krams
erzählen wo leben wir eigentlich und was
macht eigentlich das für einen sinn
neben den kommunen in den kommenden
wochen werden wir in der ukraine eng
abgestimmt mit den niederländern 12 der
modernsten patzer nützten der welt
liefern die ausbildung ukrainischer
soldaten daran wird in wenigen tagen
abgeschlossen sein und es sind wirklich
sehr moderne machen sehr schwere waffen
was sollen abgesehen davon dass das
abschießen von flugzeugen mit
luftabwehrraketen auch ein schwerer
vorgang ist aber was soll denn anderes
schwere waffe sein als zum beispiel
gebhard oder die panzerhaubitze das ist
doch einfach
dahergeredet es zeigt dass sie da
vortrag
in den kommenden wochen werden wir der
ukraine eng abgestimmt mit den
niederländer
wenn wir den kommenden wochen werden wir
auch weitere waffen liefern zum beispiel
hat die bundesregierung aktuell
entschieden dass wir mit dem system iris
t das modernste flugabwehrsystem liefern
über das deutschland verfügt damit
versetzen die die ukraine in die lage
eine ganze großstadt vor russischen
luftangriffen zu schützen auch das ist
eine entscheidung dieser bundesregierung
ferner werden wir in der ukraine ein
hochmodernes ordnungs radar liefern das
feindliche auf witzenhäuser und kippten
atelier aufklärt auch das ist eine
entscheidung die wir getroffen haben und
die die sicherheit der ukraine mit
modernstem gerät sicherstellen wird
alles was sie sagen ist nicht richtig
wir machen das was möglich ist allen
rezessionen mal
[Applaus]
präsident biden hat gerade ein sehr sehr
lesenswerten und sehr wohl durchdachten
beitragen der new york times geschrieben
über die unterstützung die die usa
leisten und die verbündeten der usa mit
dem die usa immer eng abgestimmt handeln
das will ich übrigens sagen ist aus
meiner sicht eine wirklich
beeindruckende qualität unserer
transatlantischen beziehungen dass wir
wirklich intensiv miteinander abgestimmt
sind dass wir uns sorgfältig absprechen
dass wir gemeinsam handeln und
angesichts der verlagerung des gefechts
in den osten der ukraine hat präsident
biden gesagt
man will über das hinaus was bisher
geliefert worden ist
die möglichkeit nutzen mehrfach
raketenwerfer zur verfügung zu stellen
er hat gesagt er
werde keine waffen liefern nachdem die
ukraine in der lage wäre nach russland
zu schicken
aber das was notwendig ist mit dann
dieser distanz auch von russland in der
ukraine genutzten solchen raketenwerfern
das werden die usa tun wir sind mit ihr
seit tagen darüber im gespräch und wir
haben mit den usa besprochen dass das
was dann haben unsere technischen
möglichkeiten ist auch beigetragen wird
auch das hört zu unseren entscheidungen
und natürlich ist alleine dieser aufsatz
wert sehr sorgfältig diskutiert zu
werden denn die besonnenheit die
fähigkeit abzuwägen das für und wider zu
erörtern
das wünschte ich mir auch von der
opposition in diesem deutschen bundestag
hier handle jedenfalls im geleitzug mit
unseren verbündeten so habe ich es oft
gesagt und diesen geleitzug habe ich
eben beschrieben er wird auch weiter
unsere politik bestimmen natürlich weiß
ich dass das eine situation ist das für
und wider mit großen heißen herzen
erörtert wird aber es gibt auch klare
haltungen dabei und natürlich ist es gut
sich hinzustellen zudem zu gehören die
immer sagen alles noch mehr davon noch
was davon noch was genau so wie es ganz
einfach ist zu sagen gar nichts aber das
was man tun muss ist genau der weg den
diese regierung eingeschlagen hat große
entschlossenheit mut und kluge
abwägungen das ist das vertreten
und damit bin ich bei dem liebe
kolleginnen kollegen
was wir mit dem sondervermögen für die
bundeswehr erreichen wollen
ziel ist eine leistungsfähige und
fortschrittliche bundeswehr eine
bundeswehr die ihren kernauftrag die
landes- und bündnisverteidigung erfüllen
kann weil sie ausreichend ausgestattet
es und ich wiederhole was sich am anfang
gesagt habe die versäumnisse der letzten
16 jahren von csu und cdu
verteidigungsminister und der dortigen
region schätzen die werden jetzt
aufgearbeitet und aufgeholt
das weiß jeder
es war die csu cds unzähligen geht die
spart zeit bei der bundeswehr begonnen
haben das ist die wahrheit
vielleicht holen ich bedanke mich bei
allen die in den letzten tagen
mitgeholfen haben dass wir diese
entscheidung zustande bringen können das
so kannst du tiefen und da über
parteigrenzen hinweg verhandelt worden
ist denn das was hier hinbekommen ist
ein quantensprung
und es hat auch eine konsequenz die
bundeswehr wird wohl dann die größte
konventionelle armee im europäischen
nato system
und wir werden auch alles dafür
beitragen dass wir uns auch ansonsten
weiter verbessern was unsere
sicherheitsarchitektur betrifft zum
beispiel wenn es um fragen der
cybersicherheit geht und deshalb finde
ich müssen wir den moment der hier
stattfindet auch genau verstehen es ist
anders als in früheren zeiten wo man in
paris und warschau in london in
washington oder prag angst und sorge
hatte wenn die bundeswehr so viel
stärker wahr und die deutsche armee
sondern es ist erleichterung was dort zu
spüren ist alle sind sehr beeindruckt
von diesem schritt endlich sagen sie
endlich übernimmt deutschland die
sicherheitspolitische verantwortung die
es im einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert
hatte und zwar von einer die regierung
angehören
die hilfe kam war noch die zeitenwende
und wir geben sie die wir kolleginnen
und kollegen wir bringen in ordnung was
nicht in ordnung war und deshalb ist es
auch so richtig bei unsere soldatinnen
und soldaten es verdienen dass sie eine
gute bundeswehr haben genauso wie die
bürgerinnen und bürger des landes denn
es geht um sicherheit und wir haben die
verantwortung die sicherheit unseres
landes und unseres bündnisses zu
gewährleisten
verleiht sie haben darüber berichtet
dass hier als ich das sagte beitrag
geklatscht wurde auch aus den reihen
ihrer fraktion dafür bedanke ich mich
wie ich mich übrigens wirklich ernst ich
gedanke dass es möglich war konstruktiv
das ergebnis hier zu verhandeln ich
möchte mich auch bei allen die mit
verhandelt haben intensiv bedanken weil
ich weiß es geht immer auch um konkrete
person in der lage sind dank das zu tun
was notwendig ist aber dass
sarah dass
das will ich an dieser stelle dann doch
auch sagen so zu tun
so zu tun
als wäre das jetzt alles schon mal
passiert weil die rede gehalten wurde
vor drei monaten
das ist ein irrtum das ist die größte
veränderung der sicherheitspolitischen
architektur dieses landes und ich bin
stolz dass wir das diese regierung sie
auf den weg bringen kann ich bin dankbar
dass die opposition dabei hilft
[Applaus]
1 will ich hier noch kurz sagen weil das
für mich wichtig ist
internationale solidarität ist keine
einbahnstraße
und deshalb
habe ich sehr bewusst die aufstrebenden
demokratien des globalen südens indien
indonesien südafrika senegal und
argentinien als partnerländer zum g 7
gipfel in ellmau eingelenkt
denn das darf uns nicht passieren
dass wir diese länder als bündnispartner
verlieren und das ist ja eine große
gefahr angesichts der auswirkungen des
krieges der gefahren für hunger und
sicherheit und energieversorgung dieser
länder und deshalb ist es wichtig dass
wir darüber nicht hinweg sehen der krieg
ist aus der perspektive mancher dieser
länder ganz weit weg aber die
konsequenzen ganz nah wir müssen ihnen
helfen und das werden wir tun in größter
solidarität und gleichzeitig die
botschaft aussenden die auch ausgesandt
werden muss in jedem gespräch es ist
putins krieg der diese krise verursacht
und nichts anderes
zum schluss
wir leben mit einer herausforderung wie
sie die bundesrepublik deutschland noch
nicht in dieser art gekannt hat wir
müssen etwas dafür tun dass wir in
dieser besonderen situation auch
besonders handle und dass durch diese
haushalt ausfallen das sind nicht meine
worte sondern die worte meiner
vorgängerin aus dem jahr 2020
seinerzeit hat die bundeskanzler und
damit eine neuverschuldung begründet die
deutlich höher lag als die
neuverschuldung im aktuellen
haushaltsentwurf
anders als damals haben wir es heute
allerdings nicht nur mit der pandemie
und ihren folgen zu tun sondern
zusätzlich mit einem krieg in europa mit
einer globalen energie- und
nahrungsmittelkrise und weltweit
steigenden preisen in diesen unsicheren
zeiten sorgen wir mit dem haushalt 2022
und dem sondervermögen bundeswehr für
sicherheit und zugleich stellen wir die
weichen für den aufbruch in die zukunft
das erwarten die bürgerinnen und bürger
dafür steht die bundesregierung dafür
steht dieser haushalt schönen dunk
[Applaus]